i felt that bill maher was a little
disingenuous and dishonest the other
night oh conservatives really like
applauding bill maher now because
occasionally he attacks woke-ism but he
is still a democrat he is still a lib
and he still pushes for things that are
really ridiculous so bill maher had sean
spicer on his show
and
bill maher took the opportunity
not to discuss what's going on right now
not to discuss
the
relevant political issues to today but
to focus on
the 2020 presidential election and the
january sixth were the worst event ever
in history and
the big
this was looked at by
people from both parties and they that
people have come down on the idea that
trump lost this election and you won't
say it and if you're either part of the
big lie if you or you're not
of the conspiracy it is not a big lie
the wisconsin
audit committee just released a report i
have it here you're just afraid you're
afraid i'm not afraid of anything you're
afraid of trump no you're afraid of
being honest yes you are
you're afraid of being
i have not then again i wasn't on the
campaign i did not see evidence of
widespread fraud what i did say and what
i'm telling you is that in certain
states where they sent out ballots that
were not requested in violation of a law
that should concern everybody but he
still lost the election okay
okay don't worry about biden okay so he
did lose the election trump biden's
president
did he lose the he did it's a big lie he
did he wasn't rigged it wasn't it was it
was the election was rigged okay it was
obviously rigged
they changed all the rules right before
the election what do you mean the
election wasn't rigged
of course the election was rigged now
are you saying
the election was rigged and trump
actually got more votes i don't know i
mean just sean spicer's point i don't
know i didn't you know they didn't prove
it in court so it's
you can't say that definitively
was the election stolen jeremy jeremy
boring the god king of the daily wire
made this point jeremy said the election
was rigged
but he doesn't think the election was
stolen
there actually is a distinction to be
had here
rigged is
the democrats
set up everything to give them an
advantage which they obviously did in
pennsylvania they changed the election
rules in violation of the state
constitution for goodness sakes
by pushing the widespread mail in
ballots
does this mean that trump actually got
more votes i don't know i mean like
i guess not i don't you know i mean what
to sean spicer's point biden is the
president
but please do not tell me
that the election was the most above
board election in history and if you
question it you're an insurrectionist
terrorist whatever terry mcauliffe who
is running for governor of virginia
former governor of virginia who is now
running again
during this election
refused to acknowledge the results of
the 2000 presidential election
during this election during in the year
of our lord 2021 refused to acknowledge
the results of the 2018 georgia
gubernatorial election and please enough
with the big lie you know what's amazing
do you know where the big lie
was coined do you know who coined that
phrase and where he did it hitler coined
that phrase he did it in mein kampf and
he used the phrase to accuse the jews
of pushing a big lie
to blame german general eric ludendorff
for losing the first world war for
germany
when you
use the phrase the big lie and weaponize
it against your political opponents you
are putting yourself in the position of
the nazis which the democrats are doing
right now and they're so historically
illiterate
including bill maher that they don't
even realize that they're doing it
enough with the ridiculous
shallow talking good grief people
everything is just an accusation of
racism
white supremacy nazism
give me a break
hold up thank you for watching that
video i'm glad you enjoyed it you can
get more videos like this if you
ring the bell if you subscribe they
still probably won't send you
notifications but you'll at least have a
better chance if you really want to get
updates in the full uncensored show head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]